on va rejoindre tout de suite oui après
tout de suite gérard holtz et wifi la
chanter avec sa guitare et puis je vais
essayer la compagnie entend on va
essayer voilà alors je le rejoins en
direct merci awards
bon tu commences je prends mon micro la
voilà et les paroles sont où il fallait
bien que je vienne avec un cadeau alors
j'ai pas trouvé des fleurs en revenant
je me suis dit j'ai peut-être venir avec
ma guitare pour faire plaisir à caroline
car je sais que tu adores ça j'adore
chanter je chante comme une casserole
mais j'adore chanter et surtout je
voulais qu'on te connaissent ce sous ce
soleil la toussuire soleil c'est
pourquoi sa soeur comme ça dix mois les
paroles sont non non moi je vais
chaussures tonnes non mais bon j'ai beau
chercher on peut chanter voilà on peut
chanter plusieurs choses différentes en
fait tout ce dont je parlais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire un mélange de
musique américaine et de musique
française les choses comme ça que tu
aimes le rocket
moyenne chansons que j'aime bien c'est
un grand grand grand classique dont
françois jouffa tout à l'heure qui
parlait de claude françois mais a
souvent parlé c'est blue suede shoes ça
tombe bien parce qu'aujourd'hui tu as
des chaussures bleues elles sont pas en
daim bleu mais c'est pratiquement ça là
c'est ça hein
sweet marron
quatre tournois majeurs
un film qui vient de sortir qui
s'appelle la bamba tient bien la mort
pas
m
cette amap 1 kader siens
on n'a pas regardé la série
las pavas
obama
à
par momar
tard et encore j pas plus mal payés il
va faire appel
n'est ce pas
mais on attend
la chine membre
j'aime bien les beatles avaient normal
c'est là il faut commander parole
comprend les paroles on va chanter les
titres vie des beatles est encore là
à la fin
l épi
et
nm1
ce geste
en france
ma
et
la lépi
on se connaissait pas vraiment ce jour
là la voix cassée parce que comme on a
fait la fête à abondance pour le grand
prix des reporters on a beaucoup de
chance que tu as gagné le grand prix du
grand slam et vous en êtes vous d'accord
il y aura encore des surprises de la fin
des missions puisque nous chanterons les
copains d'abord par exemple on
continuera s'amuser mais